what up y'all it's Noah Cyrus and I am
going undercover on the it's actually
making I am DB January 8 2010 ax C is
true was born in Nashville Noah Lindsey
Cyrus is my birth name I was named after
Eldon Lindsey my very great grandpa noe
has just kind of like stuck around since
I was out the womb
I guess noe no no that's it I don't
think I'm 5'4 but I'm fine with that if
I am I think I'm I at least I tell
myself I'm five five two five six but I
might be lying Noah is the fifth child
of Billy Ray in to Cyrus and the younger
sibling of tres and Miley Cyrus Wow they
forgot phrasing and Brandi she was named
one of times most thirty influential
teens of 2017 yes that is true I just
didn't really understand why me so it's
kind of like a surreal feeling that like
you know when I was 17 I was on a list
of like 30 most influential people you
know and I had just started music so
stuff before the release of good cry
collaborated with the brand pizza sign
for a line of merchandise that was only
available for 48 hours the items include
sweatpants hoodies and along with the
jar filled of noah tears that was
offered for 12 rats
that is half true half falls so I did
the collab with pizza slime and I never
once put my tears in a bottle but it
definitely caused some controversy and
pissed a lot of people off I'm an
emotional woman and concerned I cry a
lot so I thought it would be funny to
kind of like make a joke and see who
would want to buy my sadness and a
bottle and somebody started a GoFundMe
page and we had to shut that one down
real quick so that was for everybody
that got so worked up was not real but I
feel like I should do it now just piss
everyone
you do I would love to know her meaning
behind this song talking about the I've
outside that I select use this music
video there's so many meanings behind
this the song it song is really about
dread and the world of the sake of the
world that we're in but there's also
this point where I woke up and I have
this feeling about the world just so
much is changing and are we in control
of it are we not in control of it is it
a good change is this area change
there's so many amazing meanings behind
the song and it's not really made for a
belief system or a certain religion it's
really made for anyone who connects to
it spiritually without it being
religious if that makes sense
was that her dad's backup vocals yeah
that is PJ in the background he sounds
beautiful so I have him sing
throughout most of the EP with me he
does a lot of the harmonies and stuff
like that
when did she get all those tattoos damn
I've not been keeping up I honestly I
got my first tattoo at 15 and I just got
kind of addicted and I learned very
quickly that tattoos are permanent but I
covered the one that I regret the most
which was a rocking halt emoji reply
who else remembers now Cyrus as a voice
of fun I do
pretty ironic must be fun
boy being from Montana and I wonder how
I earn Miley's dad's field on Christian
country music but that being into this
time music makes me wonder how he feels
honestly he just wants us to do whatever
makes us happy can someone tell me the
point of this song referring to make me
cry like I love the song I just don't
know it's about honestly it's about a
love that whenever you're the most hurt
and they're the reason why they're the
ones that you want at the end of the day
to comfort you
which is why I've never needed you and
why I've never hated you right now and
it's kind of this toxic relationship of
back and forth love
Wikipedia 2013 Cyrus's her birthday as
an opportunity to raise funds for the
ban of using horse-drawn carriages in
New York City that's true from my 13th
birthday I called it a tweet 13 and it
was to you know shut them down in New
York because I love horses and I hate
going to New York and sing horse-drawn
carriages growing up I just rode horses
my entire life and I put in fathom the
idea of horses in New York getting hit
by taxis and going home to cement stalls
and the fact that this law you know has
it changed breaks my heart and it
actually makes me not want to go to New
York every time I have to go there
because I just hate Singapore heritage
most recently she is work for PETA first
appearing in an ad protesting the use of
animal dissection in schools SeaWorld
we did a campaign against the world
serum and then also for dissection in
schools yeah that's super a lot of
animals die and the dissection kills
animals in school so that is another
reason why I teamed up with PETA to do
the dissection kills campaign when I was
younger by SeaWorld's don't go there
Twitter canoas iris make more music like
July I don't know can I have Cyrus what
came first the chicken or the egg I
[Music]
don't know
as well as the middle school and high
school assuming I was an alto when I'm
in fact I was not I just didn't know how
to sing properly and I'm the soprano one
but what really showed me that I'm not
an out though is I can't sing July by
Noah sires to save my life if I'm being
honest with you I don't know the
difference between Alto or soprano I
just open my mouth and songs come out so
you're doing better than I can
what does that even mean I didn't go to
music school Instagram have a nice day
are you in quarantine for Corona I am I
am not left my house since well my show
was March 10 and we got the merge wrong
and we put that the date on the merge
was March 11 fans were not very pleased
I have him quarantined since that show
really which is like March 11th but I
really like you know after like the last
rotary store run I haven't run the
grocery store one time
everything's been online the last time I
did that was March 15th so that's like
the last time I really like left my
house I've just been hiding I did a
drive-by for my friend's birthday like a
little and I shot a tequila threw a
water gun at Colson for his birthday so
it was funny my corner King was rough in
the beginning I was getting really
anxious and depressed but you know I
fell off from therapy and you can't do
that you got to stay in your routine and
honestly that was you know my bad for
like not sticking on my routine because
that's the one thing that keeps me sane
so I think I got a little lazy
quarantine and I'm just like staying
focused and working music everything
that bad-boy lettering is so cool where
did you get it I got it in my friends
living room she was eating good girl
tattooed in cursive on her hand and I
was like you should get bad boy on the
other hand she was like now I don't want
to and I was like well I'll do it so
that you can at least have like a good
girl bad boy tattoo because it'd be cool
posted bad boy right there
Quorra
what is Noah Cyrus I have no idea I
don't know sometimes I like write my
emotions on paper and sing them by other
than I'm another idea why anybody would
want to be interested in me who is
taller Noah or Miley we're pretty even
be honest what should I get
a Noah sighs man for Christmas some
tissues they're issues
how old is now Cyrus
20 that's enough internet for me today
so I'll see you guys next time peace out